They back Donald Trump and want him to build
the border wall.
They don't.
Opponents and supporters of the US president
facing each other in McAllen while waiting
for his arrival.
I was born and raised in the valley and I
feel it is very important that we secure our
borders.
It is absolutely important, it is necessary
for my children, for my safety.
The wall is just a scapegoat for all the problems
that the US has.
People think that because the border wall
is going be build up, all the world's problems
are going to be fixed.
Our country's problems are going to be fixed.
But it's not true.
Members of the same community, but deeply
divided.
A couple lost their temper, the police had
to intervene.
Meanwhile, President Trump was given a tour
along the Rio Grande, where he talked to border
agents, using this trip to bolster his argument
for his signature campaign promise.
What they need more than anything is the barrier
or the wall, call it whatever you want whether
it is steel or concrete you don't care, we
need a barrier.
In McAllen, Trump once again threatened to
invoke emergency powers to build the wall
without Congressional approval.
But many in the Rio Grande valley disagree.
They don't see a reason to declare a national
emergency here.
Most people we talked to at the protest told
us they feel safe that there is no crisis
at the border, they accuse the president of
stoking fear in their community.
Even some of Trump supporters told us that
they do want tighter security, but that they
don't think that a border is going to solve
all problems.
Brandy Kennedy has lived in McAllen for twelve
years.
She says she is proud of her community.
This is the safest place I've ever lived in
my life.
So the whole idea that there is hoodlums coming
over illegally, and drugs in the streets and
cartels is ridiculous.
It is absolutely not.
She says if President Trump stayed long enough
in McAllen to see that for himself, maybe
he'd change his mind.